call of duty's akimbo weapons for the
player who feels one gun just
isn't enough dual wielding weapons has
been a staple in call of duty for more
than 15 years
and in that time we've had our share of
some very broken ones
so in no particular order let's talk
about some of call of duty's most
memorably
bus stated kimbo weapons we've got tons
of call of duty videos here on gamespot
so subscribe and check out our call of
duty playlist if you want to see more
the g18s don't be fooled by their small
form factor
because these things pack a wallet these
machine pistols have a fire rate that's
through the roof
to a point where it sounds like the
in-game audio can't even keep up
if you're a long-time fan of call of
duty you can probably hear these guns in
your head
[Music]
in fact in infinite warfare the g18 was
renamed the hornet
to no surprise the g18 was introduced in
modern warfare 2
along with the option to dual wield if
you didn't play modern warfare 2
3 or infinite here's what it's like
getting killed by the g18
last time in our broken guns part 1
video i talked about how lethal
just one fennec is in call of duty
mobile for the true experience i had to
go back and unlock the dual wheel perk
i could not believe the difference this
made this has got to be the fastest
killing setup in the whole game
since mobile controls are a little
clunky cod mobile has an
auto fire feature and let me tell you
auto fire and akimbo fenix
go together like bread and butter i felt
like a hacker just tearing through
everyone these are way too powerful
every time i play call of duty mobile i
have a big ol smile on my face
there's a lot of love put into this game
so i suggest you give it a try if you
haven't already
but please if you're really good stick
to ranked matches
it's so nice to have that option are you
taking notes warzone
no okay moving on
next up is the iconic 44 magnum in terms
of pure damage
the magnum has always been one of the
strongest handguns in the call of duty
franchise
one alone has the stopping power perfect
for close quarters combat
but with two of them you become the most
root and tootin shooting broken ass mess
of an operator
this side of the mississippi since one
bullet usually deals anywhere from 50 to
70 damage
all it takes is a second one to seal the
deal for you revolver fans out there
we've got a great loadout episode where
dave jewett
breaks down the entire history of the
revolver and its uses in both film
and video games you should definitely
check it out
[Music]
the solid 9 millimeter from black ops 4.
as a single weapon the sog may not be
the fastest or strongest smg
but when it's time to go akimbo at level
13 the sog becomes a different beast
on small maps like firing range in
nuketown these
melt enemy players surprisingly they
have a decent potential at medium range
something very uncommon for akimbo
weapons their fast time to kill is great
for catching people off guard
they also work wonders in free for all
matches just make sure you have
scavenger equipped
i can't believe i'm saying this but out
of all the guns on this list i had the
most fun
with the xmgs from advanced warfare with
major disadvantages like low fire rates
and laughably slow sprinting speed
the xmgs come off as some failed
titanfall weaponry
but if you have the patience these are
riot
they're definitely broken but in some
unique ways for example
most akimbo weapons have limited
starting ammo the xmgs have 150 rounds
each other akimbo weapons have terrible
recoil and no accuracy due to their
widespread hip fire
what is that the xmgs have no recoil and
have a teeny tiny hipfire box
add that up and you get a pair of guns
that destroy people at
all ranges these are perfect for the
jumping wall running gameplay and
advanced warfare
don't sleep on these like i did
in many ways modern warfare 2's
multiplayer was such an astounding jump
from call of duty 4.
we went from 3 kill streaks to 15 had
bigger and better guns
and of course the reintroduction of
akimbo the first gun that comes to mind
without a doubt
is the model 1887. at first we were all
fooled by this red dead redemption ash
shotgun
but as soon as word got around that this
thing was a dual wielding monster
it couldn't be stopped it was one of the
first instances i remember where a gun
got patched for being too
good like many akimbo guns the models
were so fun to use but annoying is
to be killed with they didn't take much
skill to use but for a lot of people
that was the appeal
what could be funner than running around
with these and shooting every living
thing in your pack
being dead or anything else
first appearing in modern warfare 2 of
course the m93 rafika
is an m9 variant with a three round
burst it goes by a few nicknames like
renetti b23r
and diamati whatever you want to call it
it's broken in every game it's in
within the last year both modern warfare
ranetti's and cold wars diamonds have
been nerfed
it's hard to justify using any other
sidearm when you've got this broken pair
unlocked
in fact outside of warzone they're used
as primary weapons
i was grinding up the diamondi to
capture footage and with just one i was
able to call in a vetol escort
enough said the rangers as if modern
warfare 2 didn't have enough broken
weapons
these beloved double barrel shotguns
were featured in only two games
so while our time with them was short it
was memorably chaotic
there are tons of cowboy-like guns on
this list but the rangers take it a step
further by the way they're controlled in
game
when dual wielding them the left trigger
fires the left gun
and the right trigger fires the right
one even when you equip just one
the left trigger doesn't function as an
aim down sights button
it fires one of the bullets giving you
the ability to fire both shots at once
so when you're running around with two
of these you've got four overpowered
shots at your disposal
you can fire back and forth between guns
or pull both triggers at once
and watch your enemies fly a hundred
feet in the other direction
good times in infinite warfare you're
able to
wield the hvr submachine gun if you have
the epic gemini variant
akimbo no to insanity
yes in short these two are the ump45s of
the
[Music]
for akimbo they have a pretty small
hitbox so they work a lot like advanced
warfare's xmgs
only here you can run faster jump higher
and power slide till the cows come home
the footage you're watching here is from
ryan aka prestigious key
who says he personally had the most fun
using these modern warfare
2 style with extended mags and laser
sights
and by the looks of his footage i'd say
he nailed the perfect class setup for a
good time
the akimbo fmg9s in real life the fmg9
was a prototype machine pistol
its lightweight collapsible enclosure
was designed for transport and
concealment
the prototype was brought into call of
duty modern warfare 3
and we all know how that went
at close quarters the akimbo fmg9s were
unstoppable
even today years after patches to the
recoil and hip fire spread
these two are simply menacing in 2021
the creators of the fmg9 magpul along
with zevtek
announced the fdp-9
so it looks like they're finishing what
they started since these two were only
ever featured in modern warfare 2
it would be awesome to see them return
in a call of duty title but only time
will tell
[Music]
the ump 45 is one of the best guns in
modern warfare 2
and that's saying a lot but if your goal
is to really just break the game
then akimbo is for you this was a close
call between the umps and the p90s
while the umps deal higher damage the
p90s have a faster fire rate
but in practice they're both pretty
similar and by that i mean broken
unlike the magnums or shotguns you have
a good chance of wasting your enemies by
simply holding down both triggers
and unloading in their general direction
all the dual wielding smgs are broken in
modern warfare 2
and i think that's why we don't see them
in newer call of duty games
imagine if modern warfare's mp5 had a
nikembo option
it would be nerfed into the ground but
hey that was part of the fun of modern
warfare 2.
it was a glorious mess by the way don't
try to play it now everyone's just noob
tubes
if you enjoyed the list be sure to check
out our call of duty playlist where we
have more videos about our favorite guns
maps perks and more share your favorite
dual wielding memories in the comments
below and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you